hey guys Doug Walker here well we got
new shows new location new house so you
have people on the internet right now or
just be like God do let's change I can't
take a nap everyone would like to say
you know this once he moved that's the
point where everything went downhill uh
cuz people love to do that uh they love
to pick that one point so here I'm
giving you the point uh but I digress
I apologize wearing a red shirt in the
Red Room to your I'm so probably
bleeding right now uh but definitely
you're not here for that you were here
to hear my opinions on wreck-it Ralph
and god this is like the first time I've
done a review in a while where I do I'd
to say let me tell you what I thought of
the other ones it's like holy crap an
original idea so Ram um so okay uh
wreck-it Ralph as many of you know if
you know anything about video games or
even heard a video games you've probably
heard a wreck-it Ralph the trailers have
had a jeweled video game characters in
the film uh and uh going over the
premise real fast I mostly you know if
you don't um it's about a video game
character named wreck-it Ralph was kind
of a Donkey Kong knockoff um excuse me
got text uh who's tired of being the
villain uh he doesn't like you know
destroying the buildings in his game and
then has the hero get all the worship
and the people in the game don't respect
him so he decides to go game jumping
which means that he hops into other
video games to try and achieve something
try to get a medal specifically is what
he wants he feels he's a hero if he has
a medal uh and while doing this he goes
into a couple different worlds welcome
called hero's duty which of course is
set down like call of duty and doom and
stuff like that uh and he goes into
another game called sugar Raja which is
sort of like a Mario Kart knockoff sort
of um you know it's just very cutesy but
a racing game and along the way he comes
across a little girl was a glitch in the
game you know who wants to enter the
race and of course they're gonna form a
ship but there are some problems and
complications bla bla bla bla
uh so what did I think the film uh I
really really liked it um I I thought
was a very strong story I thought very
strong characters either very likable
characters uh it's nice to see Disney do
a CG movie that's not Pixar related
though John Lasseter did produce it um
that's actually it it stands on its own
okay you know and it actually you start
had to remind yourself it's not Pixar
because it has a lot of clever jokes uh
I would say the one downside to it that
some people might have I'll just address
it now early on is that the big pushing
point of this is that there's real
videogame characters and you got Bowser
from Mario you got a zengi Finn and
bison from Street Fighter and Sonic is
in there very briefly uh but the big
thing that the sighs is that they are
not the main thing in fact honestly
they're not in it for very long most of
what you see is in the trailer that's
very important to know so if you're
going in expecting to see all these
videogame characters come in and
interact and stuff like that you pretty
much already saw it in the trailer
except one or two other you know little
scenes like there there's a cute scene
with tapper you know it's pretty funny
um I personally would have liked a
little bit more like I thought maybe at
the end uh you know during the climax
just suddenly to help maybe all the
videogame characters that they got the
copyrights for we're gonna come in had
this great big epic battle when that
thing crate like maybe pong uses you
know the ball in the two lines to knock
people out or something but but I
digress
um maybe for a sequel uh so on top of
that I say the only other the only art
weakness tomb on top of a is that they
do there so building up that goes to a
lot of different world it's really only
two um and they're very creative worlds
and they're really wonderful to look at
and it's great how much they have the
detail down of the games they're
satirizing um but it is only two worlds
and you would sort of think oh maybe
there's a lot more
jumping in it but not really it's more
focused on the simple goals of these two
characters that being reckoned profit
and the little girl the glitch um and
that they're both played very well that
is very character focused there is
actually a pretty good there's a good
reveal uh near the end which uh if it
Nicky saw this do it he was saying yeah
yeah I thought the ending revealed was
lobbyists and stuff like that as well as
things were it's like yeah was but I
didn't catch on so it's hard to say
whether or not it's obvious or not but
even if it is it's still good and makes
for a good story and every time you
think it's gonna go interaction you're
not gonna like it makes up for it it's
kind of like Hot Fuzz in that way where
you think it's gonna go in an area where
like oh no come on you were doing so
well but then they sort of no no this
was all part of her plan you see it all
kind of comes together uh so the the
jokes the jokes are good probably could
have been a little stronger I mean
they're not quite up to like let's say
the Toy Story levels but they are still
pretty smart and pretty funny um and
they're very likable characters uh with
john c reilly is reka brows very likable
uh-oh what to name is it Jane Jane Lynch
is their name at her as the commander is
great
she's a ton of but the backstory to her
that she's programmed with uh they're
very smart that they're saying she was
programmed with this backstory they know
they're videogame characters and that
and that's great um is just so funny
it's a lot of funniest images in the
movie um and the Sarah Silverman is
great as the glitch she's very very
likable um and they create it's it's so
creative this set up I think everybody
at some point has had this idea of you
know where they want to see all their
favorite videogame characters together
and they want to see em sort of jump in
between games or is there a place well
the video game characters me video game
confessions that sort of based on that
idea uh so I think everybody likes this
idea and it's great that only do they
finally do it but they did it with the
real characters for the most part like I
said wreck-it Ralph
Donkey Kong and fix-it Felix the hero in
the game is pretty much Mario um and
that stuff is just it's they do it very
well and the way they work the story
around it and with it it's very smart
and they give sort of a history and even
just the idea that this this girl is a
glitch you know but then she's her uses
the glitch to her advantage and stuff
and what it means run a game to be
unplugged and just very smart stuff and
really cleverly ties back into the story
every time it goes somewhere where you
think oh this is you know what was the
point that it comes back it actually
does have a purpose uh so I really
really like this movie especially for
the the characters and how their
motivations tie in to the story uh so uh
excuse me who would like it uh you know
video game fans I think would like it a
lot but on top of that you don't need to
know video games especially well maybe
that's the advantage of not having too
many video game characters and ever
lying too much on them is that you can
still follow it even if you don't know
much about gaming uh you know anyone can
come into this movie um and I'm sure
they were they were banking on that uh
and they explain things very well you
know for the most part every time it
starts to get a little complicated they
they bring it back to you know just that
right level of comprehending it um I
think people that like you know people
that like good characters and they like
the creativity you know if you just look
at these worlds they create these two or
three worlds uh and you look in the
background you see the design of the
characters and the you know that that
Candyland place and just everything that
they use the design there's like these
dona cops map it's like that alone is
hilarious um you know it's all wonderful
in that the hero's duty world and how
you know detail they make it compared to
the very cartoony wreckit-ralph that
contrasts alone is very very funny um so
i think a general audience would
probably really like it people who
wouldn't like it i would say if you are
looking for either a lot of humor uh
you probably won't get quite you're what
you're looking for you looking for a
straight up comedy uh because there's a
lot of moments where it takes itself
very seriously and it's justified and
works and it works within the world but
if you're looking for a straight up
laughs that's gonna have like a lot of
your favorite videogame characters are a
lot of videogame jokes it's not going to
be that many there's a few and they're
not bad but it's not going to be that
many it's not the focus um and if you're
pretty good at figuring out plots like I
said you'll probably figure this one out
fine uh if that bothers you um and like
I said there's not many worlds if they
travel too so it's not it's not a film
that's very very focused on video games
like as a whole like a lot of video
games so you're gonna go to a lot of
different video games and again do jokes
within they are gonna move on to the
next world and I gotta do jokes with
that it's mainly just a couple worlds
it's a couple characters um and if
you're fine with that you'll probably
like them okay
you know and it is just sort of like say
you know that the character is
eventually going to come to grips with
who he is and everyone else is gonna
come to grips with who he is and stuff I
think this is not a big shock um but I
thought the way they did it and the way
they explained to it whether it was very
well handled um so yeah I think that
sort of sums up you know who would like
it who wouldn't like it um like it's a
there's definitely not a big focus on
the video game element in there it's not
the focus I should say the main focus
the main focus is the characters uh so
yeah that's it for a wreck-it Ralph to
them next time we're actually going to
try something a little different still
gonna do reviews you know with the bum
reviews - except this time we're going
to try a new review show we're going to
bring my brother in on it and we're
gonna try and mix it up a little bit
we're going to try and actually start
compare and contrast opinions and stuff
like that this is one of the new review
shows we want to start doing so with the
next film maybe see if um review but you
don't see a video right under it you'll
know why you know there's a review show
coming
very shortly after if not the same time
and we're going to try that out and see
how that goes so guys that's about it
hope you enjoyed me rambling about
wreck-it Ralph and I shall talk to you
later
take care